so did you know that when Vegeta was
released we almost got Gogeta you see
when Dragon Ball was being printed in
Shonen jump back in the 1980s and 90s
the chapter before vegito's reveals
specifically stated that we would meet
quote gojita in the next chapter but of
course the following chapter came and he
introduced himself as Vegito so what
happened well the answer isn't 100 known
but our best understanding is that the
big Fusion Reborn movie featuring none
other than Gogeta was being produced at
nearly the same time this chapter was
coming out releasing in full three
months later so it's likely that
Toriyama may have seen the character was
named Gogeta in the movie and made a
last minute change to distinguish them
or maybe it was just a misprint either
way the moral of the story here is that
Vegito is Gogeta at least originally so
that makes him better in every possible
way